so your new album drops today and it's
called BB and I want to ask you about
that because I've actually never named
an album uh my name because I always
feel like it's hard cause I I feel like
I'm like multiple artists in here so why
did you do it why'd you name it BB I
think for me it was more of like my just
my whole journey and I feel like you
know I was telling somebody the other
day that when I did the Jonas Brothers
tour I remember I was I love them yeah
they're great yeah they're amazing yeah
um I was performing and I opened up for
them and when I would when I would
perform everybody like wait that's yours
that's that's her that's her song and
I'm just like it's crazy yeah it's crazy
because I feel like more people know my
songs and actually know what I look like
or who I am or what my background is or
where I come from or they don't even
know which is kind of cool which is kind
of cool yeah they think they think I'm
like English or something
I'm from New York you know what I mean
like I'm a New York girl but
I just feel like for me it was mostly
like I didn't want to like I didn't want
to like I just wanted to name something
where people could actually learn like I
want people to know more about who I am
yeah that's understandable so I think
it's time for people to know who Bebe
rexha is yeah
it's amazing though because you've been
killing it for so many years I know
that's what I'm saying it's amazing and
I think that is kind of exciting as an
artist though when you go to a show like
and you forget like you go there and
you're like oh my God I forgot about
this song I forgot about this song I
love that reminder like when you see
someone live anyway
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going
[Music]